mais d'abord l'actualité politique
dominée ce soir par edouard philippe il
crée son parti et à droite comme chez et
les rer on scrute ses intentions on
compte ses soutiens aux rêves états
on ne connaît pas encore le nom du
nouveau mouvement d' edouard philippe
mais on connaît son adn il sera
largement composée d'élus locaux des
déçus du parti des républicains par
exemple mais aussi ceux qui n'ont jamais
franchi le cap pour rejoindre la
république en marche en premier lieu
l'instant que deux maires à être
effectivement sens comment dire sans
parti depuis pour certains quelques
années d'autres quelques mois et on
avait besoin de se retrouver dans une
maison où on partage les mêmes valeurs
étanche aux idées d'extrême droite et
surtout dans laquelle les élus locaux
occuperons de la centrale ce qui est
plus le cas des partis aux fins de
l'offre politique actuelle edouard
philippe a récemment rappelé sa fidélité
à emmanuel macron qui est pour lui le
candidat naturel pour 2022 mais certains
voient dans la création de ce nouveau
mouvement la volonté de peser notamment
pour les législatives qui suivront
plusieurs personnalités de la majorité
ont confirmé leur présence samedi au
havre pour le lancement de cette
nouvelle offre politique
christophe castaner aurore bergé ou
encore le sénateur martin lévriers s
pour empêcher qu'il fasse de l'ombre à
emmanuel macron non répondent t-il car
edouard philippe n'est pas un danger
d'après eux aucune inquiétude il ya
vraiment une loyauté qui a été
réaffirmée de la part de l'ancien
premier ministre auprès du président de
la république pour 2022 il est clair
pour tout le monde que notre candidat
sera emmanuelle maintenant j'ai décidé
d'y aller pour pour le féliciter de
s'engager ainsi appelé manuel macron à
se représenter et pour le remercier
aussi de ceux dans son rôle de premier
ministre trois mille personnes sont
attendues samedi au havre pour voir
edouard philippe prendre son
indépendance en toute loyauté
edouard philippe un allié de poids pour
emmanuel macron mais un allié encombrant
aulas le thème de notre débat tout de
suite et je vous présente mes invités
bérengère bonté bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes journaliste vous publiez le
sioux les faces cachées d'edouard
philippe c'est aux éditions de
l'archipel le livre sort aujourd'hui
savons timing un an dans quel plus de
100 entretiens et 12 heures d'interviews
avec l'ancien premier ministre
j'accueille également adélaïde
zulfikarpasic ch bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes directrice de bba opinion olivier
garcia avant soir son écrivain
éditorialiste aux politiques et lætitia
culpa qui est éditorialiste de sens
public les mardis et jeudis bonsoir
laetitia en alternance avec matthieu
croissandeau évidemment alors on démarre
avec l'actuel la création de ce nouveau
parti politique est ce que ça vous
surprend bérengère bonté j'ai envie de
dire non sinon vous auriez peut-être pas
sorti votre livre aujourd'hui
non c'est assez amusant parce que cette
date à quelques jours près elle a été
annoncée il ya un an
la république une des mères qui se
réunit demain le 8 et qui va déboucher
sur ce discours très attendu de samedi
des noirs philippe avait prévu de se
réunir au havre s'était arrangé il ya
pile un an puisque fondateur s'appelle
christophe béchu mère dieu angers est
donc ce rendez vous du 30 septembre
départ on avait dit fin septembre face à
quelques jours près était prévu et donc
il fallait pas non plus être devin pour
imaginer que sortant de matignon on
avait tous compris quand même qu'il
avait un avenir cet homme là donc moi je
m'étais aussi calés sur ceux sur ce
timing là on serait à sept mois de la
présidentielle
de là à imaginer qu'il en ferait un
parti je vais vous dire fin août quand
c'est devenu vraiment clair qu'ils se
structuraient quelque chose il en était
encore et moi je boucle élus livrent à
ce moment là il en était encore à se
demander si c'était un think tank c'est
une association si c'était un parti
politique c'est un mouvement et ils
voulaient observer la primaire de l air
qui est on sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
petit peu plus complexe que ça et c'est
une une des données du timing des leurs
philippe qui fait qu'aujourd'hui comme
on sait maintenant que cette primaire
est un peu je vais m'engager sur un
indice primeur début décembre eh bien ce
je pense que ça apporte un petit peu le
vrai déclenchement du parti olivier
grassi à part dont je vous ai appelé
olivier garcia excusez-moi créer son
parti question pour cette stratégie
alors ces moments parce que pour moi
philippe comme macron qui était un peu
les charpentiers du nouveau monde là on
revient clairement à l'ancien monde
c'est là qu'on recrée des partis on se
remet d'un système purement
électoralistes et en fait on a
l'impression qu'il nous fait un peu une
françois bayrou avec un nouveau modem
pour négocier finalement déplace à
l'assemblée nationale c'est exactement
ce qu'il fait parce que finalement il
dort philippe n'a pas vocation à se
présente en 2022 manu macro est
omniprésent pour la scène présidentielle
il pense au coup d'après il pense à 2027
il est beau s'être législatives au c'est
peut-être aussi pour peser dans la magie
des prises en ciel à avoir des députés
de sa couleur politique et c'est aussi
une façon assez habile de détruire
définitivement la droite républicaine
kay déjà très affaiblie aujourd'hui on
le voit les sondages le montrent et
bertrand est à 13% selon harris
interactive est donc aujourd'hui avec
cette menace que fait peser doit
philippe finalement m kron fini
d'achever la droite républicaine pour la
ramener dans son sillon centriste et on
en reparlera ça parce que c'est
évidemment une des thématiques qui est
passionnante on va étudier peut-être
adélaïde zulfikarpasic le le socle de
popularité de d'edouard philippe c'est
vrai que quand vous tester
ces personnalités politiques il arrive
quoi régulièrement en tête toujours en
tête vous diriez quoi alors toujours en
tête depuis en fait depuis qu'il a
quitté matignon très exactement il s'est
imposé comme la personnalité politique
préférée des français on est sur une
cote d'avenir la question qu'on pose
c'est est-ce que vous souhaitez qu'il
joue un rôle à l'avenir et ce qui est
frappant c'est que non seulement c'est
qu'il est en tête mais il est en tête
très loin devant le numéro deux noms
tests plus de 40 personnes ont été
chaque mois il s'impose avec plus de 4
français sur 10 qui souhaite qu'ils
jouent un rôle à l'avenir le deuxième
c'est nicolas hulot qui arrivait à 29%
seulement donc à près de 15 points
d'écart qui ce qui sépare les deux
hommes et surtout ce qui est frappant
c'est qu'il est ils briguent la 3ème
position on le voit à l'écran mais il
est vraiment la personnalité politique
qui est la moins clivant parce qu'il
s'impose non seulement évidemment dans
sa famille d'origine il arrive très très
voilà il est vraiment à
à touche touche avec nicolas sarkozy et
xavier bertrand mais il s'impose aussi
nettement auprès des sympathisants à
l'om et surtout ce qui est frappant
c'est qui les répercutent personnalité
préférée des sympathisants du parti
socialiste
c'est ça qui interpelle alors moi je le
vois comme une espèce de réaction
consciente ou inconsciente mais un petit
peu défensive des sympathisants ps qui
se projette quand même dans un une
élection nous dit où ils se disent la
gauche a très peu de chances de réussir
à s'imposer donc on devrait intégrer la
défaite en can ils ont intégré la
défaite ils cherchent le meilleur la
meilleure alternative possible et cette
meilleure alternative c'est edward
physique mais c'est vrai que du coup il
a à la fois il peut se projeter sur 2022
sur comment est-ce que je capte un
électorat notamment l air et comment
est-ce que je vient consolider la
majorité présidentielle mais c'est vrai
qu'ils se seraient effectivement pas pas
idiots qui se projette aussi sur 2027
oui on peut imaginer qu'il a ça en tête
les thyssenkrupp a quelques infos sur le
lancement de de ce parti politique au
havre pour ne pas froisser emmanuel
macron j'ai laissé traîner une petite
oreille et on me dit qu'il n'y aura que
des maires qu'ils ont accompagné ces
dernières années mais aucun ministre et
aucun leader et l'air donc il essaie de
froisser personne il veut s'imposer un
peu comme le chef d'une majorité qui
vient à lui marc amant il a lancé aucun
voilà aucune invitation directe
voyez-vous il n'a pas été faire son
marché comme on dit et donc il attend
que l'on vienne à lui comme un leader
charismatique qui qui surplombe tous les
sondages oui avec
plutôt une des soutiens qui s'affichent
comme des élus locaux c1 c'est un peu le
voilà la stratégie qui est la sienne
pour l'instant au regard des sept cette
photo qui avait été publié par ses
rivales tout sur son compte twitter il
ya quelques il ya quelques semaines
c'est la réunion de fontainebleau voit
effectivement tous les maires qui sont
proches de
d'edouard philippe moi ce qu'il ya
quatre femmes si j'ai bien compté sur la
photo est ce que c'est à milan ac
masculin pour ne pas dire macho
l'environnement d'edouard philippe
hereng gerbaud a frappé aussi
écoutez oui c'est un univers masculin
c'est un des paradoxes de cet homme là
qui en a beaucoup en ce moment en
famille parce que politiquement pourra
dirai en personne pourra contester fait
qu'il avait un cabinet paris paritaire
qui l'avait qui l'a alors marlène
schiappa dit qu'il a été un vrai soutien
dans beaucoup de mesures en faveur des
femmes etc mais au final le la garde
rapprochée quasiment exclusivement
masculine la la république des mères est
quand même très masculine et quand vous
dites macho oui on est ce plus email
désormais bien sûr et moi j'ai très
envie que ça puisse être un élément de
débat en fait qu'on compte mais jamais
sur la table à venir lui l'a subie à
pratiquement toutes les femmes qu'il
rencontre quand il a marié ne sera pas
quand il a reçu pour entrer au
gouvernement premier rendez vous le dit
ma femme vous dirai je suis macho moi il
m'a fait la même alors je dis mais c'est
vrai doublettes et me dit probablement
pas autant qu'elles le 10 mai mais plus
que je voudrais oui donc ça peut être un
marqueur de personnalité mais peut-être
aussi un peu de psychologie de bac à
sable mais un marqueur politique ce dans
sa stratégie c'est pas ça pour le coup
c'est pas une stratégie ccc intrinsèque
mais de l'assument il faudrait plutôt
legault mais alors qu'il a lyon je pense
que ça le chagrine un peu il ya quelque
chose de au fond de lui qui est comme ça
ça chagrine pas mal aussi les hommes qui
sont autour de lui et qu'ils en ont
conscience tout en ayant envie de bouger
les choses mais mais il ya quand même un
pardon mais il ya une forme de tolérance
aussi avec avec les attitudes vous
souvenez peut-être que au moment de la
fin de matignon n'avait le monde avait
sorti une note de conseillère de
l'elysée qui trouvaient que que marc
guillaume le secrétaire-général du
gouvernement pour le site et puisqu'il a
été cité et quelques mois mon enquête me
prouve que c'est réellement le cas avait
vis-à-vis des femmes aux fonctionnaires
une attitude
il n'y a rien de répréhensible
pénalement mais c'est une réunion de 10
heures avec une femme et à qui on dit
vous ferez carrière avec votre décolleté
mesdemoiselles et ça quand j'interroge
mois le patron de matignon puis mini
vous êtes le patron de matinée donc dont
vous êtes la personne qui peut dire pas
de ça chez moi et c'est un sujet qu'il
est il qu'il agace beaucoup c'est très
frappant mon dictaphone enregistré des
battements de son pied sur certains
sujets qui a fondamentalement qui l'a
agacé encore une fois ça ne fait pas de
lui et on n'est pas dans des temps d
agression n'est pas mais il ya un sujet
de machisme ordinaire qui pour moi est
important et tant qu'à faire puisqu'on
dit on a des hommes neufs des hommes
modernes et ben alors aussi sur seyssuel
berizzo fille 46 ça ressort pas dans les
enquêtes d'opinion ou peut-être ça se
ressent après à dire c'est intéressant
parce que alors je suis pas sûr que
l'opinion le perçoivent de cette
manière-là en revanche à regarder un
petit peu justement les lignes de
clivage éventuelles et c'est vrai qu'il
a une meilleure image chez les hommes
que chez les femmes alors ça tient aussi
à la sociologie électorale et on sait
que les femmes votent un peu plus à
gauche que des hommes mais c'est vrai
que c'est de cette différence est là
mais je ne pense pas que ça transparaît
ce que quand on regarde de manière plus
qualitative ses traits d'image c'est en
tout cas pas du tout quelque chose qui
ressort en spontané là des choses
beaucoup plus comme les travailleurs il
est rassurant il est droit dans ses
bottes souligner ça voilà son caractère
extrêmement sa droiture c'est quelque
chose qui ressort très fortement mais de
manière spontanée en tout cas pas ce
sujet là jusqu'en sans vouloir non plus
en faire ils passaient tout leur mais je
veux dire ça m'est revenue de ses
différentes expériences sont quand il a
travaillé chez arriva à la mairie du
havre enfin c'est quelque chose qui est
qui et qui est présente dans toutes les
sphères d un avis mais je trouve ça
intéressant parce que si on se projette
dans l'avenir politique du douar philips
est sans doute à un point de friction
séparation entre politique bien sûr on
en a parlé de télé semble voilà que cet
homme moderne ultra populaire où tout le
monde dit waouh c'est le ramène au monde
d'avant
une question en tout cas c'est
intéressant de l'évoquer je reviens sur
ses soutiens olivier gracia là on a vu
la république des mères on a vu ces
c'est clairement à droite et soutiens
d'edouard philippe c'est plus bigarrée
si je veux dire que ça on sait
clairement à droite mais c'est une
droite qui avec qui avaient déjà quitté
les républicains c'est une droite avait
déjà rallié macron par opportunisme dès
que manu macron a été élu je pense pas
qu'au taux doit philippe aujourd'hui il
y est les soutiens de xavier bertrand ni
valérie pécresse qui eux restent malgré
tout aujourd'hui encore soudées autour
de leur candidat disons que il ne fait
que confirmer ce glissement qui
s'opèrent à droite il ya 4 5 ans il
n'invente rien ne réinvente rien il fait
juste il apporte juste un tampon de
droite sur la connaissance des manuels
macron pour bien rappeler que mendel
macron et ce rassemblement du centre
gauche au centre droit edouard philippe
et cette figure forte du centre droit
une fois de plus en fait c'est ce qui
est décevant c'est qu'on est quand même
dans une présidentielle aujourd'hui qui
est venu un peu plus sur la thématique
des idées on le voit aujourd'hui des
astuces moi je le montre et là on rentre
vraiment donc la politique politicienne
je sais pas si c'est le moment adéquat
auprès des français de créer un
micro-parti aujourd'hui alors que c'est
pas le sujet c'est pas le débat et
surtout qu'on voit évidemment qu'il
s'agit évidemment d'un intérêt
électoraliste ont pour lui et comment
peut-on penser à 2027 quand on ne
connaît même pas l'issue du second tour
2022 je veux dire donc c'est sympa mais
un peu un peu vintage tout ça moi je ne
pense pas qu'ils pensent à 2027 tout de
suite ils seraient pas partis ne fait
pas par sa tentative mais mais
d'abord moi je n'exclus pas la petite
hypothèse
dans laquelle emmanuel macron pour
plusieurs raisons possibles seraient
empêchés et ça peut plus l'arrêter fait
qu'aujourd'hui évidemment le recours ça
peut être un peu ça peut être un variant
ducobu d'incontrôlable ça peut être ça
peut faire mal et gilet jaune qui
reviennent ça peut être beau et beaucoup
de choses il à lèvres à un niveau
politique si on se rend
soit hollande on est bien d'accord mais
pas revenir jeu probablement mais je
vais dire sa petite hypothèse là pour
moi reste valable et si à un moment
emmanuel macron se retrouvent en
difficulté par exemple dans une
hypothèse de deuxième tour contre eric
zemmour je pense qu'il prendra pas le
risque de faire perdre son camp est donc
là pour le coup est dur philippe et leur
ai donc ça c'est la première chose
derrière pas abandonner cette hypothèse
non je suis je suis tout à fait d'accord
et là bien en tête aussi c'est à dire
qu'il se tient prêt il n'est pas du tout
en train de voir le coup d'après il sait
que il y a une possibilité un film
aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui qui sait à
quoi va ressembler déjà le premier tour
donc je pense que oui oui il le sait que
c'est effectivement le recours si jamais
emmanuel macron chute oui alors vous
parlez des soutiens à droite
effectivement c'est d'ailleurs dans
le documentaire mon pote de droite je
pense que la régie va me suivre là
dessus on a un extrait laurent si bien
le réalisateur lui demandent 'est-ce que
tu es toujours de droite voilà ce qu'il
répond edouard philippe
ex gauchistes posez votre question à
quoi
faut-il s'attendre
à une perche non non non non non c'est
pas choisi
posez votre question toujours de droite
[Applaudissements]
voilà toujours de droite la réponse est
rapide et elle est claire c'est
intéressant et il crut pas d'analyser la
communication politique avec ce
documentaire documentaire en trois
parties vous dites qu'elle edouard
philippe il fait le pari du temps long
oui bah il fait infuser son style son
image sa marque dans les esprits
français à sac ont servi les trois films
je vous rappelle qu'il ya trois films
qui commence en 2014 pendant la campagne
municipale 2016 quand il était le porte
parole de alain juppé pour les primaires
à droite et puis bien sûr le dernier qui
a été diffusé là cet été et le 25
septembre sur public sénat qui raconte
ses trois années à matignon ce qui est
frappant c'est la date de diffusion le
premier il est diffusé le lendemain de
sa nomination à matignon
ça tombe quand même bien c'est à dire
que personne ne le connaît enfin
honnêtement sur 100 français peut-être
deux et encore connaissez edouard
philippe donc un film pour le faire
découvrir aux français et puis là ce
troisième volet qui tombe cet été et qui
rediffusait la rentrée c'est aussi pas
mal c'est ça le faire appeler est au bon
souvenir des français puis ça entretient
sa cote de popularité et il le sait très
bien il il en joue parce qu'à la fin de
cet épisode il vous allez voir c'est une
séquence qu'on va regarder tout de suite
il laisse comme ça échapper un silence
quand on lui parle de son potentiel
destin présidentiel
est ce que tu en as puis quand tu seras
grand
enfin très bon avec la wii c'est tout
moi rigoler
non c'est pas une question légère
progression à 58
kyle au silence
alors un talent d'acteur si elles
mettront ils sont son concurrent bien
sûr ça c'est de la pure communication
ce silence veut dire tout voilà un
chaque pile enquêtait le coude françois
mitterrand l'aurait adoré évidemment ça
sert ses ambitions politiques ça lui
sert en tout il paraît plutôt cool en
train de manger des pâtes écouter du
rock en espadrilles et puis en la fois
sérieux quand il revient sur les masques
quand il parle de la crise des gilet
jaune donc c'est tout le pari d'edouard
philippe c'est de consolider bien sûr sa
place dans les sondages et de s'inscrire
encore une fois dans le paysage
politique dans lequel il était
totalement inconnu j'en appelle à son
arrivée à matignon et bérengère bonté
pourquoi vous surnommé lotion c'est un
bon titre c'est un trait mais bien
regarder ce qu'on vient d'écouter cc je
pense que vous avez en tête vous quand
on vous parle d'un sioux mais un sioux
pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui reste un
peu comme ça tapie qui observe qui
malinkés qui ruse et qui pas tapageur et
puis qui un jour devient premier
ministre d'un candidat donc qu'il était
pas qu'ils ne soutenaient pas moi je
m'appelle eu beau
et qui qui à l'ena je suis c'est une des
impôts du bouquin je suis allé
rechercher
le classement ils épient garez vous
qu'il est admissible à sa deuxième
tentative il est 100e ex-aequo dernier
ex-aequo après toussaint pas de problème
c'est un concours très difficile il sort
à la fin de l'ena 5e et personne ne l'a
vu venir personne le majeur de cette
promotion qui était benoît ribadeau
dumas qui a été son directeur de cabinet
à matignon tout le monde a vu tout de
suite qui serait malade qui serait major
darryl centimes mais c'est quoi doudou
sortie et c'est comme ça tout le temps
surtout donc là il ya eu on sort d'une
année où il a passé son temps à s'amuser
de ses silences moi il me l'a dit une
fois je vais vers le février mars
l'année dernière quand quand je l'aï
rencontré il venait d'y avoir cette
petite interview il envie ils ont donné
très peu mais où on lui avait posé la
question sur une radio président du hac
le club de foot l'an prochain au
président de la république et s'était
amusé à répondre sur le hac puis à dire
bon bah président la république vous
viendrez boire une bière au havre on en
parlera plus longuement parce qu'il
avait fait la série comme ça tout le
temps il allait glisser une option
sérieuse nous en reparlerons exactement
alors que réponse moi je vais alors je
vais me permettre de vous parler à sa
place parce que en réalité je n'ai aucun
doute sincèrement sur le fait qu'il a
envie président de la république un jour
c'est aussi clair que ça et depuis six
ans c'est aussi l'histoire de la vème
république qui fait ça le premier
ministre qui n'est pas sûr que jean
castex et en vidant bien sûr il ya
beaucoup d'exemples de premier ministre
qui ont qui ont senti naître ou monter
leur leur ambition présidentielle
pendant leur passage en réalité il ay la
part de justin
long cheminement quand il rentre à l'ena
il donne une interview à rien qu'ils
aient un bouquin sur les oraux de l'ena
et il lui dit je ne ferai jamais
politique et là ils partaient pour être
aux fonctionnaires et pour lui la
politique c'était la tentation soldes
tombent de sauf que quelques années plus
tard dans les stages de l'ena il lui ça
là ça c'est lui qui me l'a raconté il ya
un stage à la préfecture de carcassonne
ou préfet l'envoi à une réunion de
maires assez tendue avec des maires de
communes sur les rythmes scolaires je
crois est en fait il me dit j'ai compris
j'ai je me suis vu retourner la salle
chicaner quelque chose et une famille
comme indy et il me dit ça dd se parle à
lui sa bd c'est beaucoup plus qui font
que de que de faux ce n est que d'être
sur scène même pour un spectacle c'est
ça c'est ça que je veux faire c'est ça
la politique c'est d'agir cessé de peser
mais de près et me disent qu'ils veulent
être président mais je pense quand je
pense fini je pense juppé et je pense
qu'il peut finir comme juppé sr ce
syndrome de l'inaction cette pensée
qu'il est un homme providentiel d'être
populaire auprès des français c'est le
cas d'alain juppé on peut le tester à
l'époque en 2017 alain juppé telle une
place et est préférée des français
pourtant il a échoué primaire de la
droite est aujourd'hui est tombé dans
l'oubli le politique et donc il peut
avoir ce syndrome de l'inaction de
penser que le peuple va venir à lui et
de ne pas le provoquer et donc je pense
que c'est à la fois sa qualité mais
aussi sa plus grande faiblesse et
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est clairement pas
dans le domaine de l'inaction de l'homme
providentiel je pense que le français le
secret par le débat edouard philippe est
un peu trop en retrait aujourd'hui pour
s'imposer dans le débat mais c'est ce
que j'allais dire en fait je pense que
ce pari de du long terme que vous
évoquez il à double tranchant et c'est
aussi pour ça son os qui le crée son
parti parce que il peut vite
effectivement souffrir d'un vide et 2
est tombé aux oubliettes il faut pas
oublier quand même que sa popularité
actuelle elle se construit
principalement sur la gestion de la
crise qu vide il avait cela a
effectivement de particulier que
contrairement à jean castex il a
toujours plus ou moins été plus
populaire qui emmanuel macron lorsqu'il
était premier ministre en tout cas un
peu au début du quinquennat en tout cas
à partir de début 2008 il est toujours
plus populaire mais c'est ça se joue à
deux trois quatre points près et puis
pendant la crise qu vide où il donne
l'impression d'être celui qui au front
qui en première ligne qui prend les
coups qui y va il creuse l'écart
progressivement et au moment une petite
matignon il est à 54% d'opinions
positives dans l'opinion manana coin à
38% seulement deux cas 16 points d'écart
mais tout ça ça ce sas est fondé sur
l'action qui est effectivement
aujourd'hui ça fait un an les français
n'ont encore en tête il ya effectivement
tous ces petits signaux avec notamment
ce film qui entretient une certaine
notoriété visibilité mais il a besoin
d'exister parce que si son projet ont ce
cas-ci pas le projet avoué mais si on
parle de ton nom et de 2027 il ya cinq
ans devant nous au moins cinq ans et
demi il faut qu'il existe alors là il
indique que l'âge des retraites l'âge et
la retraite c'est rare weedon là j'ai 67
ans et on sait que c'est une mesure
forte qui est on va en parler de ça 2
comment comment il fait entendre ces
différences j'aurais d'abord qu'on
reprenne un extrait qui est quand même
important dans dans la relation entre
edouard philippe et le président de la
république qui est le moment où edouard
philippe dit clairement son soutien à
une candidature qui n'est pas encore
officiel mais à une candidature du
président la république c'était dans
l'émission sept à huit sur tf1 pour
l'élection présidentielle mais 2022
je soutiendrai le président de la
république
je pense j'espère qu'il sera candidat et
je le soutiendrai pour trois raisons la
première c'est au fond de la loyauté et
la cohérence la loyauté à l'homme ça
compte en tout cas pour moi ça compte et
la cohérence pendant trois ans j'ai été
son premier ministre je me suis démené
pour essayer de mettre en oeuvre les
engagements qu'il avait pris devant les
français je vois pas comment aujourd'hui
je pourrais dire je n'ai aucune envie
dire mais c'est pas comme ça qu'il
fallait faire ou ou à si on avait eu
faute voilà donc loyauté et cohérence
c'est la première raison la deuxième
raison c'est que pendant trois ans à
matignon j'ai approché beaucoup plus que
ça n'avait été le cas non tout le reste
de ma vie la présidence de la république
et le président la république
j'ai vu combien cette mission ce mandat
était incroyablement difficile et je
pense que emmanuel macron effet d'un
métal
dont je ne vois pas beaucoup la trace
dans tous ceux qui sont candidats
aujourd'hui à l'élection présidentielle
je pense que c'est très important
la loyauté ne pas être le traître on
pourrait presque dire olivier grassi
accès c'est aussi une pierre dans le
jardin des manuels macron kiki qui a
lâché françois hollande est ce que vous
vous entendez ça dans les sous titres de
la déclaration de d'edouard philippe non
j'ai pas entendu ça mais bon je pense
honnêtement qu'il doive philippe est
assez cohérent dans le sens où je pense
en effet qu'il est qu'il est loyal et il
est loyal aussi pur opportunisme et
loyale au jour parce qu'il n'a pas
d'intérêt aujourd'hui la concurrence
emmanuel macron qui est quand même bien
placé dans les sondages après il je
pense sincèrement qu'il va filer par une
forme de fascination pour mener le
maquereau je pense qu'à une fascination
sincère je pense qu'il a je pense qu'il
goûte on peut avoir des rapports
peut-être compliqué quand il était
premier ministre mais je pense qu'une
fascination pour l'homme pour
l'éloquence je pense qu'ils étaient très
avertis de macron même pour sa campagne
donc je pense qu'il est noyauté aussi
admirative pour macron qui adulent
impressionné qu'on était président et
honnêtement honnêtement je pense qu'ils
se voient toujours aujourd'hui parce
qu'est venu macron ne peut pas faire
deux plus deux quinquennats et donc va
se poser la question de la succession et
surtout qu'en marche ne se passe au
grand chose et on le voit aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas dire que dans le parti en
marche il ya un candidat naturel qui se
dégage comme étant le successeur
spirituel emmanuel macron edouard
philippe finalement fait office de celui
qui serait le plus proche d'incarner
cette figure présidentielle au sein du
dieu romain crânien finalement donc il a
conscience de cela et je pense que
plutôt que le trahir il préfère
l'accompagner pour être après son fils
spirituel sur quoi repose leur relation
mais en gironde
il y a une forme d'admiration je suis
assez d'accord je pense il ya une
reconnaissance il sait pertinemment que
trois ans avant d'entrer enfin trois ans
avant de sortir de matignon plutôt et
d'avoir cette popularité insolente il
n'était rien oui c'est un visage
nationaux il le sait pertinemment il
sait exactement ce qu'il lui doit et il
sortait d'une campagne mon dieu vous
souvenez vous de l'état de la droite
alain juppé qui était son candidat avait
perdu la primaire il françois fillon
qu'il l'a gagnée a été obligé de voix la
fin est allé jusqu'au bout enfin on sait
dans quelles conditions après laffaire
pénélope donc il ya il ya une énorme
reconnaissance quand vous dites loyauté
moi je vous dit est ce qu il fait escale
dans son esprit quelque part hollande
françois hollande il ya quelque part
dans le haut fond de les voir philippe
antenne ruffenach parce que l'ancien
maire du antoine ruffenach quai en gros
il a eu il a deux mentors on réellement
dans tout le début de son parcours qui
sont antoine riverains qui lui est qu'il
a amené progressivement et du csa n'est
pas un long fleuve tranquille du tout
contrairement à ce qu'on croit mais
quand même qui lui a transmis les sharp
aux arts et donc qu'ils sont à 6
aujourd'hui et puis alain juppé qui lui
avaient confié les rênes de l'ump en
2002 voilà et c'est de là ce sont les
deux personnes avec qui l'a interrogé
quand énorme et emmanuel macron lui a
proposé d'entrer au gouvernement c'est à
dire quand même d'une certaine façon le
trahir et l'air aussi et c'est là
quelque et la question de loyauté autant
alain juppé a plutôt soutenu autant
antenne ruffec étaient farouchement
contre et il ya ce caillou dans leur si
je puis dire dans leur relation qui est
vraiment resté comme une souffrance en
tout cas du côté d'antoine ruffenach
même si rien merci mme edwards fille dit
personne ne peut savoir tadoussac n'est
plus là pour en parler aujourd'hui il ya
quand même quelque chose qui est qui et
qui s'est un peu cassée à ce moment là
et c'est quelque chose je pense qu'il a
toujours en tête parce que la loyauté
pour le coup dans son éducation est
quelque chose d'extrêmement fort ok il
ya cette petite trahison je pense qui
est dans un coin de sa tête si on va
s'offrir une petite pause musicale dans
cette émission vous connaissez forcément
cette chanson du
ma préférence samoa
moi j'avais envie d'écouter la guerre ça
fait toujours du bien des côtés du
julien clerc et il en fut bissé thomas
différence à moi c'est subtil comme
transition bref les différences et
comment il va faire jouer ces
différences deux citations des leurs
philippe on est dans une interview au
magazine challenges c'est le 30
septembre la dette voilà ce qu'il dit
sur la dette la dette est un problème
éminemment politique cette question doit
être débattue pendant la campagne afin
que les français votent en connaissance
de cause je sonne l'alertent compter sur
moi pour revenir dessus dans les
prochains mois ensuite il enchaîne dans
la même interview la première réforme
affaire et celle des retraites vous en
parliez à l'instant laetitia la seule
solution raisonnable et donc d'allonger
la durée de vie active en repoussant
l'âge de la retraite à 66 67 ans et
d'ailleurs ça lui vaudra un recadrage
signé de son successeur jean castex on
est sur tf1 le 30 septembre écouter oui
il faut faire la réforme des retraites
qui conduira à travailler plus longtemps
jusqu'à 67 ans ça nous n'avons jamais
dit ça ça c'est l'opinion des doigts
fibre ça c'est dans la jeu
n'a jamais été fixé à 67 ans bon alors
que comment est ce qu'on peut se
projeter dans cette dans les sept mois à
venir dans cette dans cette campagne
électorale on sait que emmanuel macron
va sans doute se déclarer le plus tard
possible c'est c'est son intérêt mais
comment vous imaginez vous le
positionnement la stratégie d'edouard
philippe est ce qui peut être finalement
un petit caillou dans la chaussure du du
président candidat à force de faire
entendre sa différence bérengère bonté
là il faut essayer de comprendre le en
même temps philippiens l'hémophilie
piste ne sais pas kiki qu'ils prêtent
allégeance il ya trois semaines
effectivement au président de la
république et qui quinze jours plus tard
donné une interview à challenges avec un
programme économique clairement de
droite et à la retraite mais il ya aussi
le le
la conduire le contrat jeune
la rigueur budgétaire vraiment le
liquide des comptes publics est vraiment
son logiciel principal en permanence ce
qui est rare et on verra bien si un jour
il accède au pouvoir quand je dis c'est
rare ça fait 30 ans quand qu'en france
il y en a pas de budget équilibré donc
c'est clair que visiblement le pays
attend ça dans ce qu'on comprend bon
mais donc il va y avoir sept ce
positionnement économique moi c'est ce
que je comprends on ne suis pas devin
mais ce positionnement économique très à
droite et puis politiquement quand même
une habileté qui consiste à ne pas
fâcher ni les alarmes m ni les ailes
rdc auprès des sympathisants sa chambre
il ya une échéance au 4 décembre pour l
air qui fait qu'il va de toute façon
devoir rester prudent pas fâcher les
élèves de rester c'est ça aussi le
silence et c'est je pense vraiment que
tu es tu là je pense que ces trois
années à matignon il ya une faillite qui
est vraiment notable c'est l'absence de
dialogue avec les gilet jaune et le sait
en fait tout son programme économique si
vous lisez le livre qu'il a écrit avec
gilles boyer et pour lequel il a fait sa
tournée en france il ya tout il ya tout
son programme il ya tout sur les
retraites sur la dette il a aussi tout
un pan sur l'écologie parce qu'il sait
bien que c'était quand même une déceler
jambe malade avec notamment la démission
de nicolas hulot et et c'est
effectivement un homme qui a déjà tout
pensé
à l'avancé qui va pas pas faire avancer
son programme après avec des petites
touches comme ça dans la presse parce
que pour l'instant il peut dire ce qu'il
veut il est libre edouard philippe
jusqu'à maintenant et ce n'est pas parce
que il se met dans le sillon des manuels
mâcon oui au moment où il y aura poussé
le rupteur c'est trop loin et on ira la
loyauté à l'est plus c'est qu'il est
libre et des d'ailleurs il réécrit même
l'histoire parce que quand il parle de
son départ de matignon dans le même
temps lille c'est un peu flou enfin il
s'est fait virer enfin générer un moment
il va aussi assumer ça et puis le
raconter à l'endroit donc il me semble
que pour l'instant il joue l'électron
libre emmanuel macron fait savoir par
voie de presse parce que ça se passe
comme ça maintenant là c'est dans l'obs
qu'il a était furax c'est pas lui qui le
dit évidemment c'est un conseiller qui
te parlent pour lui furax du petit
manège que jouer edouard philippe en
faisant comme ça j'y vais j'y vais pas
est donc là pour l'instant c'est un peu
on se montre les muscles et on va voir
comment ça se passe dans les prochains
mois olivier gracia comment vous
l'analysez là justement cette
perspective 17 mois et de la campagne et
donc du rôle d'edouard philippe là je
trouve en l'occurrence je dis pas du
tout présidentielle de philippe parce
qu'il est encore dans son rôle le
prémunit ce qu'est nous parle de l'âge
de la retraite de la dette il par le
sujet complètement technique on ne
connaît pas ses légions de la france ce
qu'ils pensent de la france qu'elle son
ambition sa vision en politique
étrangère il reste même sur des sujets
qui lui incombaient qu'on était premier
ministre on qui raison ce rôle
suffisamment de politique technicienne
qui fait pas rêver les français quand il
dit qu'il faut faire campagne sur la
dette aujourd'hui personne ne parle de
la tête dans les débats je ne pense pas
que la question de la dette soit le
sujet préféré des français et ceux reçus
sur lesquels il faut débattre pour
gagner une élection dont guiderait mais
nous dire que c'est la campagne de
l'argent magie
exactement donc je pense qu'il reste
malgré tout un technicien il se confine
à ce rôle de technicien dont vous parlez
de différence pour moi il n'y a aucune
différence qu'une aile macron si les
différences techniques n'y a pas de
différence de fond sur l'essentiel il
est profondément macro compatit lille le
reste et le demeure et macro et en cela
bien plus présidentiable que lui mais
est ce qu on pourrait même aller plus
loin dire qu'il ya une sorte d'accord
tacite entre entre emmanuel macron
edouard fini vous en parliez rapidement
tout à l'heure pour fragiliser bien sûr
l air fragiliser le candidat ait l'air
xavier bertrand ces deux hommes qui se
respecte ses bagnoles à qu'on n'a pas
choisi qu'un prémunissent pour rien même
si évidemment il a été viré de matignon
je pense qu'il a gardée comme une forme
de reconnaissance parce qu'il en serait
pas là aujourd'hui samuel macron donc
évidemment qu'un accord tacite si un
accord tacite depuis le début pour
détruire la droite des républicains qui
aujourd'hui déjà très fragilisée et au
fur et à mesure on le voit ou la mesure
les sondages avance les républicains et
qu'il n'est pas impossible que xavier
bertrand soit un jour sur la barre des
10% au rythme auquel ça va aujourd'hui
est en tous les cas je pense que c'était
la volonté première du président et pour
le coup il a bien réussi son pari aleri
2 une fille car pas si je fais toujours
attention à bien pour lancer la bretelle
votre votre nom c'est quand même un
atout politique cette popularité le fait
de ne pas être clivant c'est une carte à
jouer pour pour emmanuel macron drac en
cas d'actes mans est vrai dire je ne
sais pas s'il ya un accord tacite mais
si l'accord tacite y avait ils préparent
mieux s'y prendre parce qu'effectivement
en prenant la parole sur des sujets qui
sont des sujets notamment les réformes
alain forme des retraites la question de
la dette qui sont des sujets
effectivement plus cher à l'électorat de
droite électorale a le temps à l air il
s'adresse davantage à ses lecteurs et
ses électorat est donc ce faisant que
jouer un petit peu le rôle de rabatteur
ci ont cependant apprécié où il est
plutôt il se positionne plus comme le le
fils spirituel en tout cas celui qui
sera le successeur potentiel emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui voilà ils aident à
continuer sa stratégie de
siphonnage de la droite républicaine
enfin aujourd'hui effectivement et
bertrand à 13% on ne sait pas ce que va
donner la séquence désignation du
candidat monrovia pour l'instant la
droite est en mauvaise posture donc il
vient creuser ce sillon là dans un
contexte où même si effectivement on ne
peut pas exclure la petite possibilité
que la campagne du fait d'un événement
extérieur viennent empêcher manuel
macron aujourd'hui quand même manuel
macron est en bonne position au sortir
d'une crise sanitaire que finalement les
français trouvent qu'il a plutôt pas si
mal gérer à la fois sur le plan
strictement sanitaires mais aussi en
termes d'accompagnement économique il a
remonté dans l'opinion illégaux
quasiment à un français sur deux qui a
une bonne opinion de lui donc
aujourd'hui la stratégie c'est plutôt
emmanuel macron qui se représente est
dans ce cas de figure edouard philippe
joue effectivement la carte de voilà je
viens l'aider à ratisser sur encore
davantage à droite mais angers remonte
quand il était à matignon il est déjà
entendre sa différence vous vouliez
évoqué je crois que le discours de
déconfinement
ccc à quelle occasion de l'assemblée sa
maîtrise et sa le 28 avril 2020 se
dévouent déconfinement c'est le 11 mai
qu'une pin date qu'on a tous en tête
c'est mon anniversaire
ici c'est vous dire les rigoler quand
vous disiez le 11 mai je vais enfin
pouvoir faire la villette et c est donc
le 28 avril faut se souvenir que manuel
que edouard philippe était pas favorable
à la vie confinée aussi vite donc il a
évidemment il s'est exécuté entre
guillemets il a annoncé un déconfinement
11 mai sauf qu'il a annoncé cette date
du 11 mai comme un point de départ et
non pas comme un des confinement est en
gros il est apparu fin ce discours étape
de mon point de vue le le plus frappant
le plus habile politiquement de ses
trois ans à matignon c'est à dire que il
vient annoncer une perte du 11 mai tout
en disant mais il se passera rien et on
va se donner le mois de mai pour
observer et des efforts mais nous
déciderons si les bars et les
restaurants peuvent ouvrir et hans dans
ce cas ce sera effectif début juin tout
ça le discours je les vérifie a été relu
par le président de la république
tchèque il fait ça de
finalement ils gardent la main ou dans
un moment où il l'avait pas mal prise
puisque on a été beaucoup souligné il a
quand même été là où emmanuel macron a
tardé à prendre vraiment le les affaires
en main pendant sa période au début de
la crise il convient lui effectivement à
plus tôt je pense qu'on serait beaucoup
de sa stature dans cette danse et 3 4
mois très difficiles mais là je trouve
ça assez magistrale politiquement et
emmanuel macron n'a rien pu faire donc
il ya en apparence il suit président il
annonce ce déconfinement contre
lesquelles il est enfin
il était dit opposé et puis en fait ils
l'ont dit mais vous savez quoi j'ai
compris que vous étiez inquiet donc on
va faire ça un plus tranquillement et on
va faire son sale en deux trois quatre
semaines c'est magistral oui c'est
intéressant effectivement olivier grassi
à cir alors on continue on faire un peu
de politique fiction mais bon c'est pour
ça que c'est passionnant aussi imaginons
emmanuel macron réélu la stratégie
d'edouard philippe pendant ce second
mandat ça va être quoi de ceux de
s'éloigner petites touches par petites
touches de faire entendre sa différence
ou alors de de jouer le jouer le fils
spirituel comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure je pense qu'il est très caméléon
ça dépendra des sondages d'opinion et si
le deuxième quinquennat de macron et
populaire simenel macron parvient à
mener des réformes que les français le
soutiennent et que son quinquennat se
passe bien il n'y a pas de raison que
doivent philippe s'en émancipe arrêt au
contraire avec mini black on ne va pas
se représenter bah forcément il ya une
place qui va se créer donc je suis
d'accord et vous il ya quand même un
vrai risque est il le risque que ce soit
le troisièmement oui le troisième
quinquennat macron via edouard philippe
et que les français on est un peu entre
guillemets marre de cette politique donc
c'est un risque politique pour lui aussi
philippe ça risque politique mais si
vous voulez d'un philippe n'a pas de
différence majeure a connu la crau et je
ne vois pas comment même lors du
deuxième quinquennat va pouvoir se
démarquer des manuels macron parce que
s'il continue à faire de la politique
technicienne et avoir des divergences
technique avec macron des divergences de
fond a calmement peut-il s'en émanciper
tout le paysage politique en temps de se
restructurer au jour on le voit
l'extrême droite se divise la droite
républicaine explose donc quel est le
rôle d'edouard philippe concrètement
dans la redéfinition ce paysage
politique donc finalement sa meilleure
chance au contraire c'est de coller à
son candidat est de coller manuel macro
doit pas commune possède - cip et que
les idées qui sont les sirops
aujourd'hui à moins qu'ils nous fassent
un virage populiste à moins qu'une phase
un virage souverainistes ou un virage
protectionnistes loyer mais s'il reste
dans cette fibre là aujourd'hui a pas de
raison qu'ils sont des marques sur le
fond donc je ne vois pas ça d'émanciper
bérengère banques pour conclure il va
falloir quand même que emmanuel macron
s'il est réélu trouve une majorité et
pour ça edouard philippe va être peut
être précieux si on oublie la petite
hypothèse dont je parlais tout à l'heure
on entend parler de 2022 et qu'on se
projette vers 2027 il faut quand même
pouvoir gouverner les cinq ans ça va
être compliqué et donc le port phillip
en créant ce parti
imagine des candidatures manifestement
alors attention à pas pour être lui-même
député de chantant beaucoup président de
l'assemblée nationale je vais vous dire
il me l'a dit je l'écris il a détesté
être député j'ai détesté ça une ville
burke les voilà donc en fait on va on va
oublier ça mais il va l'idée d'être chef
de parti de pouvoir créer cette
composante de la majorité qui pourrait
devenir le navire amiral en rassemblant
agir en rassemblant la gauche de barbara
pompidou enfin alors ça va les rendre
vraiment c'est impossible de dire
aujourd'hui ça va dépendre vraiment dû
de l'es22 des scores que fra emmanuel
macron à l'arrivée enfin il ya tellement
d'inconnues il ya beaucoup d'inconnues
on est très prudent nous sur les on en a
même souvent des instituts de sondage
qui reconnaissent que la période est
quand même très particulière où vient
voilà où on est en train de beaucoup
s'exciter sur sur notamment eric zemmour
alors qu'il ya énormément de français
qui en fait se sont pas vraiment décidés
d'accord là-dessus vraiment la prudence
voilà une prudence j'aime bien terminer
ce débat par le mot prudence merci d
avoir participé c'était passionnant